I'm just a kid that grew up in the
projects man I ain't nothing special I
tell people all the time don't I'm not
nothing special I'm I I'm this dude
right here if I'm walking through the
airport and I and you stop me right and
I see on your face or your energy is
[ __ ] up and you say hey man I'm a big
fan
and we start talking you know I mean I
missed several flights talking to people
because they needed that [ __ ] they
[ __ ] needed me to be a person as
opposed to JB smooth so that's how I see
life you know I mean if if you need it
I'm gonna give it to you and and why not
however one day I was in a super in a uh
on a soup store and and it was a guy and
his girlfriend I overheard them talking
in the next aisle right and he had a
suit on and a [ __ ] tie and I heard
her saying you're gonna get the job
don't [ __ ] worry you can get the job
right I peeked around the corner and the
[ __ ] that she picked out was [ __ ] up
it how it was the worst [ __ ] ever the
worst combination of [ __ ] I said nah I
can't let this guy do this I don't
[ __ ] know this man but I can't in my
right heart
let this man go to this job interview
tomorrow with that [ __ ] on right I
went over there I said I'm sorry you
know I can't let you do this bro he said
I'm gonna fix you I said he said oh my
God JB I said hey man how you doing
anyway [ __ ] JB right now I'm gonna fix
your [ __ ] right quick you're gonna get
this job tomorrow because I see you have
determination I see you you're
determined to better yourself but you
can't wear this stupid [ __ ] right here I
said it's very generous of you check it
off take that [ __ ] tire off that
stupid ass tie take all that [ __ ] off I
I got this [ __ ] damn near naked
take all that [ __ ] off put these
pants on put that jacket on put this
tire on put that pocket square on I
don't put a pocket square in find a
pocket square that's interesting you
know why because you need something you
you need a conversation piece right and
that's what life is about A Conversation
Piece you need something that's gonna
attract the person's eye or their
interest that's gonna buy you time to
figure this [ __ ] out I'm telling you how
I am good at this [ __ ] I didn't have a
[ __ ] show oh well I just fixed
[ __ ] Howard hey don't you I
mean this is a first of all how
magnanimous of you to go over to
somebody your busy guy you go over and
trust him wow you've got a lot of [ __ ]
to do I mean that job tomorrow
I don't [ __ ] know me